from retail therapy to increasing Public
Safety there is a lot to be excited
about in North Las Vegas these projects
among the highlights from today's state
of the city address mayor Pamela Goins
Brown delivering the address from
Aliante Casino
in 2022 an incredible two-thirds of all
Southern Nevada companies incentivized
by the state selected the city of North
Las Vegas as their home
here's a look at the economic growth the
city of North Las Vegas has seen
including more than 60 thousand new jobs
the city has renovation plans for
downtown and the new Helios Medical
Campus which will make Health Care More
accessible for North Las Vegas residents